[Music]
thank you everyone for coming to our
talk and today we're going to tell you
about how you can make your service its
more reliable using staff driver so
today we have essentially four things
that we want to tell you about first of
all we're going to talk to you about why
DevOps YS re kind of how do these things
help you solve reliability problems then
we'll tell you about three specific
things that GCP and stackdriver do in
order to make it possible for you to
achieve a story principles on
stackdriver and on GCP so we're going to
tell you about how to measure success
with service level objectives we're
going to tell you about how to improve
your service level resiliency by having
better alerting and better debugging and
then we'll tell you about how
transparent SLI is help you get shared
visibility into Google cloud platform
so I'm les long johns I'm a staff site
reliability engineer and I've been
working at Google as a essary for about
ten and a half years and it's been
across eight different teams so I kind
of spanned everywhere from consumer
facing products like Google flight
search to all the way down to low level
storage like Google Cloud BigTable and
now I work on the customer reliability
engineering team which I'll tell you
about later but the key mission that we
have is we help GCV customers build and
operate reliable systems and I'm Marie
cosgrove Davies I'm a product manager on
stackdriver focusing on logging I'm new
to Google but I've been in ops for a
long time and I've had a number of job
titles including sre product manager now
and support and engineering so first of
all I wanted to lead off by telling you
about how does SRA help you improve
reliability but before I even do that I
kind of want to lead off by talking
about why should you care about
reliability why should you care about
operations and this may seem obvious to
some of you but who have done operations
support others of you it may be a new
concept right that as people who develop
software we tend to spend a lot of time
thinking about you know when does my
feature ship okay you know I spent a
month shipping my feature I spend you
know six months shipping my feature what
happens afterwards and turns out that if
you spend a month developing your
feature it might take a month worth of
support work later
or it might even take ten times as much
you might wind up spending for every
month that you spend developing a
feature it may end up having someone
spend a year supporting it so it's
really really critical that we think
about how do we improve the operability
of our services to lower the cost of
ownership of our services so s3 and
DevOps try to solve this problem so why
is this problem so bad if you think
about the way that we used to operate
services I was assisted min way back in
the day right we used to have a world in
which people who are product developers
wanted to ship features as quickly as
possible
and then what operators who are told
keep the system as stable as possible we
want a hundred percent and these two
interests are in diametric opposition to
each other right you have frog
developers who are speaking the software
engineering language you're saying why
is make these not out yet and you have
operators there saying my boss will
punish me if I don't get a hundred
percent uptime you can't ship that
feature right so that's not a very
healthy state so how do we get out of
this state the good news is we have some
lessons that we've learned from the
practice of address from the practice of
making sure that your product management
and your software engineering teams are
on the same page as each other
right that's what agile is about advil
is about kind of reducing that barrier
reducing friction shipping smaller
increments faster and the good news is
that DevOps is a way of solving this
problem and solving this wall between
development and your software operations
team right and since that you need to
break down that wall so DevOps is kind
of an abstract interface it says that
it's a set of practices and guidelines
that say you should make sure that you
dismantle these walls between IT
operations software development and so
forth but it doesn't say exactly how do
you go about doing that right it leaves
a lot of it up to you as a person
implementing it to figure out what you
want to do in comparison essary or site
reliability engineering it's a set of
practices that were originally developed
at Google and have spread across the
industry it's much more prescriptive it
says here are some practices here are
some concrete beliefs and philosophies
and here is a job role you'll notice
that as much as people like to hire for
DevOps engineers there is
such thing as a DevOps engineer whereas
you can hire at a site reliability
engineer and have a relatively clear
idea of what does that job description
mean so what is in that job description
right the core idea behind a series
solution to this problem of the wall
between development and operations is
that we have to use data to guide our
decision-making sre says that we need to
treat operations just like any other
part of software engineering that we
need to really engineer things right
that we need to write automation to deal
with our problems that we need to not be
doing things by hand all the time and
that furthermore we can't bolt
reliability on after the fact that we
have to make sure that our systems are
engineered to be reliable right from the
start in terms of what s3 teams actually
do right like we are a solution for
having your systems run at large scale
scalably reliably and efficiently so I
don't have time to go into kind of all
of these detailed practices kind of core
competencies that a series are expected
to have for more information on that you
can go to a talk tomorrow afternoon but
I did want to quickly summarize kind of
what are the what are the areas right s
eries think about metrics and monitoring
how do we know whether our systems are
working how do we debug them how do we
make sure they're scale systems can
scale up appropriately how do we make
sure that we can push software into
production in a safe manner and when
things do break how do we make sure that
we get the system back within parameters
in a reasonable amount of time and
overarching all that we like to think
about the culture how do I keep
operating the software at scale without
causing myself to burn out not today not
tomorrow but a year from now two years
from now three years from now so that's
kind of in general what we think about
assessories and you may be asking okay
so you've said a bunch of stuff how does
this relate to DevOps so I said earlier
that that DevOps was a interface right
that was an abstract interface that said
here are some general ideas it's up to
you to figure out how to do them so
these are the five areas of DevOps
DevOps says that you need to reduce your
organizational silos it says that we
need to have an idea of failure as
normal rather than expecting 100% it
says that we need to gradually roll
things out that we need to gradually
change our processes
and then we need to use tooling and
automation and that we need to use
measurement as the centerpiece of
everything so it turns out that SRA and
DevOps are not that far apart from each
other and that every single practice
that DevOps says you should have an
implementation for essary does this so
today we're going to tell you about two
specific ways that SRA implements DevOps
specifically we're going to be telling
you about error budgets and we're going
to tell you about how to reduce the cost
of failure so hopefully we can go into a
fair bit of depth here so that you have
an idea of concretely how can staff
driver how come do you see me help you
in each of these two areas summary why
don't you tell us about error budgets
all right so I'm going to talk a little
bit about error budgets and SL OHS now
one of the core observations of site
reliability engineering came from been
trainer sloths who's the head of all SR
is a Google and he noticed that a
hundred percent is the wrong target for
everything like pacemakers maybe nuclear
missiles maybe but pretty much
everything else you don't need a hundred
percent reliability and why is this if
you're running an app the network is not
a hundred percent reliable your users
phones are not 100% reliable they can't
tell if it's your app or the network or
your phones also additional levels of
reliability require additional expense
Google has observed that for every nine
you add a reliability and we'll talk
about what that means in a minute you're
adding 10x the expense so it gets much
much more expensive you hire ops people
you have to have additional fallbacks
and fail-safes and you have to build for
it since we're not the airline industry
mostly we don't need to so how do we
figure this out we use a concept called
error budgets and in order to define an
error budget product management NSR e's
we'll talk and we'll figure out what we
think the users are going to be happy
with and from that we subtract whatever
level of availability we think the users
need from 100% and the amount that's
left is the amount we're allowed to be
down in a given window so that's our
error budget once we have an error
budget we need to track it it's really
important that we monitor the actual
availability because otherwise we don't
know how much of our budget
gone through it's like if you have a
budget for spending and you don't track
how much you spent then it's not all
that useful and when you're monitoring
that it gives you a control loop for
your error budget if you have a ton to
spend then you can do more releases you
can have more features if you run out or
you're running though you need to be
more conservative because you know that
your users are going to be unhappy so
how do we measure a reliability
what is this metric there's a naive
approach which is to say okay well we
can figure out availability it's the
number of good minutes over the number
of total minutes and that's the amount
of time a service is working there are
some advantages to this approach it's
super intuitive and it's pretty easy to
measure for a continuous binary metric
like uptime there is one major
disadvantage which is how many of us are
running services that are actually up or
down it's really hard for distributed
systems to make sense of this so there's
a more sophisticated approach that you
may want to use as well which looks at
interactions you take the good
interactions over the total interactions
and that's the fraction of real users
for whom the system is working another
advantage of this is it brings the focus
back to the user who's really the person
were concerned about in the first place
so this handles our distributed request
response service as well and enables
cases like is something that's down and
not getting requests do we care no
because we're not getting any
interactions if you a few of our
services are down in the are getting
requests what's our availability we look
at the interactions there we go
this is hard to read short for me at
least when I think about 99% or 99.9
percent or 99.99% it's a little
difficult to to keep those straight
because they're all really similar
they're all really high numbers it's
more useful for me to think about the
error budget that I'm allowed per 30
days for instance if I have three nines
of availability that's 43 minutes of
downtime if I have four in my nines
that's four point three two minutes
so there is a dramatic difference if I'm
operating a system in how I need to
react to an outage if I'm expected to
have four nines of availability
the other really interesting thing about
this of course is that we're assuming a
hundred percent down here but earlier
Murray you're talking about bad
interactions and good interactions so if
I were serving 10% errors I might still
be able to have 99.99% of my requests
complete successfully over 30 days for
up to 40 minutes if I were only a 10%
down rather than a hundred percent down
so let's just be a lot more nuanced
about approaching this yep but that's
real hard to represent in a table so
this is what you get a glossary of terms
before we go into more of this I'm going
to be talking about a several of these a
service level indicator or SLI is a well
defined metric of good enough and that's
what we were talking about before your
metric that helps you figure out your
error budget a service level objective
is a top-line target so you combine this
with an SLI and that tells you what your
goal is and a service level agreement is
a legal agreement between you and a user
if you fall below your SLA then there's
some sort of penalty usually you will
pay that the user we won't really be
talking about SLA in this talk because
neither of us is a lawyer and we think
the operation side is more interesting
so to talk concretely briefly about what
an SLA is and what an SLO is you can
think about an SLO as being like I want
this request to the homepage to complete
in 300 milliseconds if it completes in
300 milliseconds the SLA is good and if
it completes in more than 300
milliseconds masla has gone sour the
users are not quite happy and the SLO is
the top-line target that says that we
expect 99.99 for instance percent of
those requests to complete successfully
over a window to make it a little bit
more concrete that's exactly right so
how does stackdriver help you with SLO
monitoring we have an EAP product that
allows you to define track and alert on
SL o--'s directly within stackdriver
monitoring I'm just going to walk you
through the UI it's very intuitive the
first step is to figure out if you're
going to have a latency or availability
SLI if it's latency you'll define a
number of milliseconds the second is to
look at the period in this case we're
looking at a week or a month and the
third is to look at your goal or your
SLO
now based again on our research three
nines you can get from well engineered
software four nines you can get from
well engineered operations and five
nines you need a well engineered
business that's really focused on
availability and as you'll see from
these very cunning dollar signs that we
put on here it gets incremented more
expensive for every nine you add so you
may want to think about doesn't really
matter if your users see downtime for
four seconds per month maybe maybe not
it's an important thing to think about
what is your specific use case and then
we have a review where we confirm that
it looks right we submit and we start
tracking so once we're tracking our SLO
within stacked or ever monitoring this
is what it looks like we get three
graphs availability in this case in the
calendar week and it shows us what our
SLO target is we have our era budget and
how we're doing and we have our SLO
compliance so in this case we're not
doing so great not doing well at all so
now that we've defined our service level
objectives you may ask that's great but
how you actually defend them how do you
actually make sure that you meet your
service level objectives so let's talk
about the life cycle let's talk about
how do we manage to run a control loop
how do we manage to keep our services
running according to the service level
indicators and the expectations so
typically your service level objectives
are met like maybe you have 0.5% error
0.001 percent errors but in general and
your users are happy everything is fine
but inevitably faults do happen in our
systems whether it's a code push whether
it's a config push or a surge of user
traffic something will happen inside of
your system that is a fault at that
point what happens is your service level
indicators start going sour because
users are having a bad experience and
stackdriver SLO might eventually let you
know that your error budget is in danger
so you're alerting might fire and then
we have to do things as the people who
are responding right we have to see is
everything a hundred percent down
globally if so I might want to involve
our people can I do something quickly
like draining his own if so maybe I'll
do that
but then after that we wind up spending
a lot of time in the course of figuring
out what happened
this loop we wind up having to formulate
a hypothesis of what we think broke in
our system and then we wind up having to
test the hypothesis and actually verify
is this actually what is going on in my
system or did I come to the wrong
conclusion about what is actually broken
and assuming that you've identified the
right thing then you go and develop a
fix maybe it's provisioning more
capacity maybe it is reverting the bad
rollout but you have to do a little fix
and you have to test the fix and ideally
everything goes back to normal
right everything goes back to nominal
conditions and your SLO is met again
unfortunately how many of you have ever
had a situation where your first guess
was right about what broke in the system
right how many of you it happens every
single time no one's raising their hands
good none of you are overconfident right
like we spend a lot of time because our
hypotheses are not always correct or our
solutions are not always correct right
so we wind up going back to square one
over and over and over again so it's
really really important for us to both
have high-quality alerting to make sure
that we find out quickly but without
waking us up too much and then we need
to make sure that we're actually getting
to testing and formulating hypotheses
relatively quickly so let's start the
higher Thursday a learning bit right we
want to make sure that we don't burn out
that we're not getting page 30 times in
the middle of the night at 2:00 a.m.
every single day at the end of the day
what matters is that we have to monitor
the symptoms of what our users actually
seeing and not every potential root
cause what do I mean by this well so
users care if they can use their service
and getting alerted about things that
don't actually impact your users doesn't
really matter right does it really
impact your users if one of your VMs has
its hard disk fill up does it really
matter probably not but it kind of
depends on what your users are
experiencing so what about if your Paxos
quorum changes or what about if the CPU
load and one machine is too high or what
if the queue length on your on your on
your on your caustic use too long or
what if your task restarts or what is
the kernel panics right like all of
these possible things that could
possibly go wrong
not every single one of them is worth
waking up for so it
turns out that there's a better way of
thinking about this right because if
we're already measuring your service
level objectives your service level
objectives are measuring user happiness
so what you care about is figuring out
is your user Happiness impacted for
instance if I had an availability SLI
that said this is the fraction of HTTP
500s that I'm willing to serve and any
more than that is not acceptable
that is a end user symptom how many 500s
am i serving and I can use that to my
advantage to replace all of those other
alerts that I showed you right and get
rid of them because all I care about is
are my users seeing errors or not but
there also needs to be another strategy
to this because we need to make sure
that we don't have too many false alarms
right but that we also detect low level
depredations
in our systems so we have to go back to
our service level objective and say
what's an acceptable burn rate and how
will I know quickly enough to react in
the event that I'm going to consume
weeks of my error budget in a matter of
hours or minutes right as well as being
able to keep track of a mice having 10%
more errors than I'm allowed right am I
getting instead of 0.1% errors 0.11%
errors over a longer window so this
means that I need to think about what
are my thresholds right I need to think
about the math I need to say if I'm
overspending and I'm spending five hours
of error budget in a single hour
I should probably fire off a page right
I should probably wake someone up and
have them immediately deal with it or if
I've overspent by five percent or 10
percent over a few days it's been going
on for a few days it will probably take
multiple weeks to burn through my error
budget it can wait to the next business
day it can wait for someone to look at
it's still virgin but not waking someone
up urgent and that way you get enough
time to get that statistical signal is
something actually broken right so
essentially what we've done is we've
said if we overspend by too much within
a given window for instance one hour
that we need to fire that page but also
if we burn faster than five or 10 times
the rate that I'm allowed in my budget
for instance if I wind up burning
through seven hours of error budget in
five minutes a
get notified right away there's no need
to wait the full hour similarly we can
talk about the slow burn case right we
can say okay I'm going to measure over
three days and if I see 5% more errors
than I expect then I'm going to file a
ticket I'm going to get a JIRA ticket or
whatever right or if I even cross that
threshold within one day I can still get
a ticket and deal with it and it will be
fine
so the good news is you don't have to
implement all that math yourself because
stature over SLO will deal with that
problem for you stack River SLO will let
you send alerts when your error budget
starts being exhausted it will project
out into the future and it will say if
I'm going to exhaust my error budget
within a certain window of time then I
need to be alerted or if I have less
than 10% of my error budget for the
month remaining or for the week
remaining to alert me and that is how
you get rid of all of those potential
cause based alerts and instead replace
them with service level objective based
monitoring so that's great right like
we've now addressed the time to detect
problem but let's talk also about the
time to resolve problem because that's
also an equally important part of having
a resilient service so when users see
errors right now we have our service
level indicators going sour stackdriver
asked a little alerts us because we're
burning through our error budget too
fast what do we need to do as I said
earlier in the debugging cycle we need
to prioritize the speed of our
mitigation and recovery so this is where
a technique called layer peeling comes
comes in to good effect and it helps us
localize problems within our stack what
zone is it coming from which kubernetes
pot is it coming from right these are
useful questions that we need to be able
to answer so I'm showing you how Google
s eries debug cooling using our internal
infrastructure which has been influenced
stackdriver to develop features that
help everyone do it rather than
requiring you to be a google essary so
in this example for instance let's say
that I've been paged for a latency
service level indicator right that I've
started seeing that my 95th percentile
latency has gone over a hundred
milliseconds so I might need to do
something like ask a question like hey
can you break this down for me by zone
within the region so if I do that then I
might get useful data that says hey us
West 1b has been slow for a while but
that's not where the excursion came from
the excursion came from us west 1a and
then I can drill down into u.s. West 1a
and I can see that it's two specific
replicas that are better slow and then I
can even do something more sophisticated
and say you know what show me a heat map
right - show me the details of what's a
distribution of requests that are slow
and then that will give me a signal of
for instance all of the queries on this
task are slow because of the fact that
there is a noisy neighbor and then I
might drain it away from that machine
right so it provides you with a
actionable way of drilling down into
your data and the good news is that this
is fully implemented inside of
stackdriver
inside of the metrics Explorer so you
can go into the metrics Explorer and you
can ask questions and you can tell it to
filter and then you can tell it to group
by a specific thing so in the earlier
example I said I wanted to filter by
region and group by zone and then I
wanted to filter by zone and group by
pod for instance and then filter by pod
and then group by individual task number
so that's how we think about being able
to apply this SRA technique from Google
inside of stackdriver so stack of our
metrics Explorer is really handy for
doing these drill downs because if you
can't localize problems within your
stack you're taking random guesses right
you're kind of you're kind of playing
whack-a-mole seeing whether you're your
latest hypothesis actually is where the
problem is it's better to not guess it's
better to know by exploring your data by
the tabs of where it came from the
second technique that I'm going to tell
you about with regards to helping you
with debugging problems faster and
reducing your time to recover is joining
to be able to cross correlate problems
inside of your stack what do I mean by
cross correlating problems in your stack
well often it turns out to be the case
that we have pushed something not to any
one individual kubernetes pod or any
individual zone or region but instead
that something has happened under the
hood for instance
maybe someone went and silently updated
the Java Virtual Machine across our
entire fleet right so if you look at all
of the data you might just see noise
because of the fact that there's no one
particular place that's coming from some
tasks are slower than others so how do
we get useful signal out of this what we
have to be able to do is we have to be
able to combine latency data with other
data such as what version of the kernel
were running for instance so we do this
all the time at Google where we add
additional information that is collected
elsewhere in the system and combine it
with existing data and once we have that
exist that additional data we can go
ahead and say hey I want the average
latency by kernel version and if I do
that I get signal out of my noise and
that signal tells me hey that kernel
version suddenly started having a
regression where previously all I saw
was noise so how can you do this inside
of staff driver you may ask the answer
is that inside of the Metris Explorer
any other view within stats reiver
you can select not only location based
information but you can also select for
system properties that are embedded
inside of the data that you're exploring
for instance you can export the
container image ID out of your
kubernetes cluster in order to get a
delta between two different values for
instance in this example we have set up
a kubernetes pod to serve 500s at a very
fat rates to serve five hundreds very
quickly because it's not taking any time
to do any real work and then meanwhile
that the control group is serving a
regular workload and taking a normal
amount of time to do it so being able to
do this break down by version not
necessarily localized to any one
particular location is really really
helpful the other thing that's really
cool is that we have upcoming a feature
that will allow you to issue custom
queries that are not done through the UI
and are instead done by typing in
expressions so this lets you combine
data that you wouldn't ordinarily be
able to combine for instance being able
to calculate how many CPU seconds does
each query take that my system has
receive
right where you have to take the total
number of CPU seconds on each task and
divide it by the total number of queries
on each task which are metrics that you
wouldn't ordinarily be able to combine
so this core idea that I'm trying to get
across to you is that having your
metadata available to you inside of
stack in size of staff ever wondering
and having the query notation language
available to you
is a critical tool for being able to
formulate and test your hypotheses and
it lets you find problems that are not
necessarily tied to specific location so
you can today do resource metadata based
queries easily within the generally
available product and we have stacked
requiring notation that's in preview
that will allow you to arbitrarily join
these metrics together and if you're
interested in learning more putting this
to work feel free to talk to me
afterwards or come to the fifth 9:00
lounge on the second floor of Moscone
West the final technique that I wanted
to show you for reducing your timer
resolve it's really really powerful it
has seriously changed my life as an SRE
and Neveu cheek the technique is called
exemplars that lets you pinpoint
problems within your stack by letting
you reason starting from specific
examples what do I mean by this an
exemplar is essentially an association
of something high cardinality with your
existing distribution based data so it
makes your distributed traces really
really useful and actionable for you it
makes your high credit card Anneli data
tags really really useful in actionable
view the way that it works is that we
keep inside of distributions the notion
of a time slice in our bucket for
instance the window between 2:50 p.m.
and 255 p.m. and a value slice which is
for instance the values between 50 and
60 milliseconds so for each of those
buckets we record up to one example of a
query exhibiting those behaviors for
instance a stack driver Trace that
exhibits that latency during that time
window and then we can show you in stats
River monitoring which buckets have
samples and let you go look at the
samples in detail so as I said this is a
technique inspired by Google a series
we've been using this for several years
now and what do we
actually use it for a Google the answer
is that we use it for looking at long
tail problems for instance it would be
prohibitively expensive for us to record
the amount of time that every single
physical machine in Google's fleet took
to boot however what I can do is I can
record only one example for each of
these common case time values but I can
also record one example for each of
these outlying values and I can find out
as a person who maintains the fleet of
machines which specific machine should I
be looking for that had a slow reboot
time or for instance another thing that
I can look at is if I have a service
level indicator that is based off of a
black box prober for instance if I had a
storage system where I was measuring how
quickly does it take to write a query
into the system what I might observe is
if I had a less sophisticated monitoring
system all I would see is that the 99th
percentile is slowly creeping up over
time however the cool thing is that this
heat map gives me a visual
representation of the fact that more and
more of these queries are taking close
to 100 milliseconds but that there's not
really that many queries over that value
so I might ask questions like show me an
example of a query that takes 100
milliseconds right show me example of a
query somewhere in here that is starting
to become very slow and I can then click
on it and find a statue ever trace
corresponding to that slow event so that
I can start looking at this long tail
problem rather than having to look
through 20 or 30 different dashboards
and guess what I think is happening so
this feature is going to be available
soon in stackdriver that lets you
overlay individual stature iver traces
onto a heat map of your latency x' and
display it alongside your service level
objectives so you can go directly from
having a service level objective
threatend who's seen concrete examples
of queries that caused your service
level indicators to become unhappy so
that you can start debugging and
formulating hypotheses faster with these
culprit traces in hand it helps
formulate a hypothesis it helps you
figure out
which tasks do I need to go to which
kubernetes pod do I need to look at
right in order to figure out where which
loves do I need to look at right because
it has a concrete time stamp and machine
name to go look at you still need to be
able to dynamically evaluate queries
which is where the earlier section on
joining data comes from but even
formulating the hypothesis is the thing
that we find we need to optimize for so
exemplars in stackdriver are a way of
combining sector or trace and stacked
River monitoring all in one view and
getting you the insights that you need
faster so now you've identified a
problem and you think I might be Google
what should i do Marie so Liz talk to
you through some techniques that Google
s areas use in order to debug more
effectively and I'm going to show you
something that Google is providing to
you right now today that will help you
easily identify whether a problem that
you've seen is because of Google now
often the first thing that we'll do when
we're debugging is to try to figure out
roughly where the problem is coming from
is it my code is it the network is it
the infrastructure that can be a really
tricky thing to figure out so Google's
transparent SLI is help you answer the
question of is this problem coming from
the infrastructure they give you the
ability to quickly understand if an
issue you're seeing is correlated with
an issue in GCP and they give you per
project metrics about your requests to
help you answer this question how might
you use them for triage if you've gotten
alerted by one of your slis
it's trending towards violating your
error budget this gives you a single
place to go to look at the GCP services
the ear products depends on so you can
tell and then for support if you do
identify an issue when you call Google
support you'll be looking at the same
graph and that helps make sure that you
start the conversation on the right foot
that you start the conversation with a
mutual understanding of the problem so
you can move quickly towards resolution
so to view these again these are your
requests so they're per project and
they're broken out by a number of fields
in the metrics Explorer today you could
go look at this right now but please
paying attention to our talk wait until
after you'll search for consumed API and
when you do this you'll see there are
four options request count quest latency
request size and response size there are
a number of different labels supported
this is a subset that I've listed here
the whole list would have been totally
illegible instead of slightly illegible
but this allows you to break it down by
method by project or by service or by
response code maybe you're suddenly
seeing an uptick in a specific response
code and you want to dig in and then as
with all metrics and stackdriver you can
use group by or filter to help refine as
Liz was talking about earlier so how do
you use these what we expect you to do
with these is to look for correlated SLI
degradation your products SLI is
trending in a bad direction see if the
GCP products that it relies on are also
having anomalies look at a baseline see
what it looked like last week or the
previous day so that you know that it's
not some sort of a cyclic thing that
wouldn't necessarily lead to an issue in
your product and use these to drive
support conversations this is going to
help you have really efficient effective
conversations with Google support things
not to do please don't assume this is an
SLA for Google we are giving you this
for information to help you debug it's
not an SLA and please don't call every
time there's an outlier I'm sure you
have better things to do and I'm sure
support folks do as well
and lastly set up alerts based on your
SL eyes don't set them up based on ours
we care if our users are having trouble
but you ought to care if your users are
having trouble not if Google is being a
little wacky if you'd like to learn more
about these there's an demo area on the
first floor of Moscone West if you go
all the way to the back of the room
we're near the folks in the red shirts
stackdriver PM's are hanging out there
for the whole conference so come talk to
us there's also a blog post coming this
week to the Google cloud blog where you
can learn a lot more so to conclude
today we talked about four different
things we talked about why should you
adopt essary techniques how does s3 help
solve operational problems that you may
be having and then we talked about three
specific ways of the
applying these essary techniques about
how to measure your success of your
customers using s ellos how do we reduce
your time to resolve and your time to
detect using essary techniques and how
do we debug problems that are somewhere
between Google and your own code by
using transparent slis so the key
messages I want you to walk away from
today to walk away with today is that
SOE techniques help you solve your cloud
reliability problems it may be really
easy to click a button in the GCP
console and get ten times as many
servers you can't get ten times as many
operations staff at the click of a
button so it means that we really need
to invest in automation and engineering
for operability in order to be
successful in our cloud deployments and
furthermore I want you to walk away with
the idea that having product development
and operations at each other's throats
is the healthy dynamic it doesn't need
to exist that if you are running your
service to a same set of metrics if you
have error budgets and s ELO's but it
provides you with common language and
flexibility to decide how fast can I
push without impacting my users
experience how can I make sure they go
get both adequate reliability and also
shipping our users features as quickly
as possible the other thing that I
wanted to mention is that GCP helps you
right we're here to help you achieve
higher reliability we're here to help
you achieve higher operability and the
way that we do that is that we embed SR
concepts into stackdriver to help you
operate more like an SRE and that our
products build in all of these s3 best
practices so that you can have lower
cost of ownership so that you can reduce
the tension between your teams and so
you can scale up so I promise I tell you
a little bit more about my team the
customer reliability engineering team so
we're a set of experienced Google site
reliability engineers and we've shift
your focus instead of focusing on
individual GCD products we focus on
helping our customers be successful
helping our customers be reliable and
what form does that take well we help
our customers set serviceable objectives
that are meaningful to their users we
help people do reliability reviews so
you can tell is my application
engineered to meet
service level objectives that I think
we'll meet will make my customers happy
and if not we'll give you a list of
items that will help you decide where do
I want to invest my time to make my
system more operable we also do shared
monitoring right summary told you about
having visibility of Google service
level indicators to you the customer
however we also think that it's
important to have support on the same
page that it should be possible for you
as a customer of GCP to expose your
service level indicators and objectives
to us so that support can see on one
page your service level indicator being
impacted and a GCP service level
indicator being impacted and be able to
debug and know is the problem fixed or
not without having to call you up and
ask you is it better yet so we do things
like shared of learning as well so
wolves get proactively notified if a
number of customers start experiencing
an issue with their service level
objectives in a correlated fashion we
also help people that are large
customers for instance retailers with
critical periods like Black Friday and
then we help you with ongoing operations
things like doing a joint postmortem
whenever there's a outage maybe there's
something that you could do to mitigate
and that we could do to mitigate there's
not a reason to do only one of them we
should do both and then we help people
be more reliable all the time whether it
be looking at your design documents or
helping you do disaster drills so you
can learn more about essary
both from reading the site reliability
engineering book the first one which is
available for free online at Google comm
re you can also go and pay us a visit at
the fifth nine lounge which is located
on the second floor of Moscone West and
there we're distributing a book print
copies of a book called the site
reliability workbook which just came out
today fresh off the presses will even
sign a copy for you and furthermore
there's a book coming up in the next
month called seeking essary which was a
written by a person who doesn't work at
Google and is a compendium of industry
best practices both from Google and from
outside of Google the site reliability
workbook also includes lessons from our
customers another place that you may
want to go to learn more is to attend
Jess and Anne's talk at 4:45 p.m.
tomorrow I believe it is all it is in
Moscone West
so with that we have ten minutes for
questions so please raise your hand and
someone will bring a microphone around
and we will try to answer any questions
that we can with the remaining time
thank you very much for listening to us
question down there in the middle please
please pass the microphone down hi
it's on it's on those all those metrics
there seem like you can you're pulling
them from API is your stuff
can you pull out all that information
also from Google local answer from
Google
I guess the Google load balancer metrics
are given to you through staff driver
right I haven't seen we've been using
Google Oban answer for a while and I
have not seen anywhere to pull response
codes at times and anything so right now
we have built engines in the middle
between google gulp and answer and
whatever the backing is just for to pull
out metrics so after seeing all your
presentation I was really curious on how
we can get metrics out of the Google
open answer
can you come chat with us at the
transparent US allies absolutely we'll
figure it out then really appreciate it
any other questions can someone run that
microphone over there please
and then after that we'll run the
microphone over there to the end and
then we'll go back over hello right go
ahead
losers do you support custom sources for
the ASL ice that is something that we
are working on we decided that it was
most important to prioritize people's
kind of HTTP statuses and latency first
before we worked on supporting custom
sli custom metrics so that is something
we're very much interested in we're
interested in your feedback like we said
this is a early access over there
someone can run that over there and as
that's happening I think we forgot to
mention please rate our talk in the app
so that we know how we can do better
next time this might be a unfair
question but you're introducing a
culture shift and thinking that
sometimes my executives might have issue
with how do you have tips or case
studies on how you know introducing SLI
versus you know uptime improves their
business yes I you want to attend Jess
and Ann's talk at 4:45 p.m. tomorrow
which is all about the culture shift
there is also a concrete customer case
study at b-59 lounge I believe on
Thursday afternoon where we'll have a
customer of that I've been working with
for several months called Marketo which
will be talking about their experience
with adopting their essary culture over
here in the front so my customers it's
not about like uptime it's about serving
X amount of requests by Y date you know
how would I um design metrics around hey
we're getting close and this is
dangerous that is the difference between
a serviceable objective and a service
level agreement is that you want your
service level objective to be set more
aggressively than your service level
agreement so you will get paged before
you run into the danger zone and fall
afoul of your legal obligations so you
might want to set for instance a service
level objective on throughput with the
idea being that if your service or
objective starts degrading right like if
you have your throughput degrade below
the level
you would need in order to complete
everything in the requisite amount of
time that you would start getting a
learn about it does it help great oh
sorry so you mentioned alerting on SLO
violations instead of alerting on root
causes
in my experience root causes sometimes
our leading indicators of SLO violations
how do you feel about that that and like
how do you how do you approach that if a
root cause is very very very strongly
correlated in an advanced predictor then
it winds up sometimes being a good idea
to alert in advance however most of the
time that is not true most of people's
potential causes are in fact only
potential so I would say it's probably
okay to have maybe three or four
potential causes it's probably not okay
to have 100 right you kind of have to
have balance in all things at the end of
the day it also depends upon your window
to react right if you have a three nines
SLA that gives you enough time to
investigate something and if you have a
five nines SLA or sorry if you have
those five nines SLO maybe you're better
off implementing some kind of automation
to deal with the condition that Radel
reliably predictably leads to
degradation and service right you would
rather write a robot to do that for you
rather than alert you with hey this
thing that's you know hey this thing's
in danger and there always leads to a
problem and you always do the same thing
why don't have a robot do that for you
other questions over here in the front
it's coming yeah it's coming it's coming
so there are a lot of Google services
that we use where there is a time for
data propagation so for example you know
when you add a user to a group in G
suite or when you change an I am you
know role or something like that it says
could take you know minutes or it could
take up to 24 hours how do you decide
your internal targets versus what you
say in the documentation what that what
that Delta really is that's a product
management thing marine hahaha thanks
Liz you're a real pal it's gonna vary
depending on the service and what it
will depend on it's exactly what we
talked about which is what we think the
users are looking for so for something
like adding an iam role you probably
expect a much quicker turnaround whereas
if you're sending logs to like a storage
bucket for cold storage then you can
wait yeah I'm more thinking what the gap
is though so like a lot of times we see
that a propagation light could take up
to 24 hours but the reality is it's like
five minutes so there's a huge gap
normally we love that question on that
is an example where the service level
objective and the real user experience
have diverged from each other and in
those cases it is usually a thing we
recommend as an s3 best practice sorry
if it make more work for you Murray
right but we usually recommend as a best
practice to either make sure that the
SLO is reflect reality or who or to
degrade reality in order to match the SL
O's right in order to make sure that
people get predictable consistent
performance so yes you're right to note
that that is that that is a gap and that
is something where we probably should
either tighten one or loosen one right
like where you have when you have an
aspirational SLO and they any actual on
the ground SLO they're better defacto
different from each other that's a
problem yeah you typically wouldn't
expect them to be orders of magnitude
apart
exactly you not orders of magnitude
apart so we'll go ahead and make that
slower then
any other questions
one more question we've got two minutes
left so you talked about choosing your
slis to match what your users care about
howdy is is there value in trying to go
beyond just an HTTP 500 in that you know
sometimes a 400 is actually you know a
problem in our client that the user is
it's still a problem to the user
but those can be a lot harder to detect
and understand an ease of way that gets
to Murray's discussion of measuring user
journeys rather than single requests so
if you can measure an entire user
journey for instance measuring not just
you know did loading the homepage of my
shopping website work but was I in fact
able to add an item to a cart and
check-out right that's going to be a
much more robust situation so the same
thing goes for HTTP for hundreds right
like our users experiencing what they
are expecting to see or users expecting
an abnormal condition and that's
something that you need to make sure
that the best possible SLO is a is a
critical user journey but you have to
start somewhere right and imperfect SLO
is better than no SLO so start measuring
otherwise you're just taking stabs in
the dark and so a better framing of that
might be something that's not a 200
would be a failure rather than a 500 is
a failure all right excellent thank you
all for coming and if you want to find
us afterwards you can find us at the
fifth nine on the second floor of
Moscone West
[Applause]
[Music]